don't wake up let's go the elephant's  need us look at that baby got a baby  what is that a face only a mother could  love  sir many of us find you handsome I was  talking about the elephant you have  until tomorrow night to fix that me make  those ears disappear don't look at me hi  baby Jambo welcome to the circus brought  them here no matter how small  [Music]  yes something very rare you have wonder  [Music]  you have magic  come with me  we should saw all that other things  wings  [Music]  your miracle I wasn't number  okay Big D this is it just like in  rehearsal except the lights music firing  crowds you could do it  quite alone  [Music]  fly  you